allez moi un peu de vous
tout va bien
comment ça se passe avec votre soeur
tout va bien et le travail tout va bien
vous savez ce que j'aimerais que vous
arrêtiez deux minutes de dire un
tout va bien
[Musique]
non tout ne va pas bien
vous êtes quelqu'un de bien parti mais
vous laisser trop les gens profiter de
ces méthodes fonctionnent c'est apaisant
c'est libérateur j'ai l'impression
d'avoir pris de la drogue en actions
n'est jamais brider je pense que cela
vaut plus ou moins qu'un effet dr larmes
je serai
ceci est un peu trop original pour moi
j'ai aucune confiance
bref
[Musique]
tout ce qui m'intéresse c'est que vous
trouviez votre équilibre
si on ne se fait pas confiance nous ne
sommes plus rien que vous fait confiance
je vous fais totalement confiance
vous venez de vivre ce que nous appelons
dans notre jargon une révélation
félicitations
et la séance est terminée